>> I KNOW THERE'S AN OUTRAGE
ABOUT PROTESTS THAT HAVE BEEN
PEACEFUL TO DATE.
WE'VE CERTAINLY CONTINUED TO
ENCOURAGE THAT OUTSIDE OF
JUDGE'S HOMES.
THAT'S THE PRESIDENT'S POSITION.
>> Harold: THE WHITE HOUSE
REFUSING TO CONDEMN PROTESTS
OUTSIDE OF SUPREME COURT JUSTICE
ALITO.
CRITICS HAVE ACCUSED HIM BEING
SILENT ON THE PROTESTS AND
ENFORCE A LAW THAT MAKE IT
ILLEGAL TO PROTEST OUTSIDE OF A
JUDGE'S HOUSE TO SWAY A CASE.
A FEDERAL JUDGE WHOSE'S SON WAS
MURDERS SPEAKING OUT ON THE
THREATS.
SHE SAYS LAWMAKERS NEED TO ACT
NOW.
>> WE'VE BEEN TAKING THE FIRE
FOR MONTHS NOW, YEARS, IN FACT,
AND NOTHING IS BEING DONE TO
PROTECT US.
THIS SHOULD NOT BE A PARTISAN
ISSUE.
THIS IS AN AMERICAN ISSUE.
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT
PUBLIC DEBATE HAS A PLACE AND
THAT'S IN THE PUBLIC FORUM.
IT DOES NOT HAVE A PLACE IN
FRONT OF JUSTICES OR JUDGES
HOUSES.
>> Harold: JUDGE, I REMEMBER
THAT AWFUL TRAGIC CASE.
JUST TO SEE THAT JUDGE MADE MY
SPINE SORT OF SIT UP HERE.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
THIS IS NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE,
THIS IS ACROSS THE PART LINES WE
SHOULD ADDRESS.
>> Jeanine: SHE WAS APPOINTED BY
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
SHE LOST HER SON.
HE DIED.
HER HUSBAND WAS SHOT.
HE WAS ON AMERICA'S NEWSROOM ON
DANA'S SHOW TODAY.
SHE WAS ON AMERICAN NEWSROOM.
IN WESTCHESTER, WE HAD A FEDERAL
JUDGE SHOT BY A LITIGANT.
WE NAMED THE COURTHOUSE AFTER
HIM.
JUDGES ARE THE TARGETS OF
PRAISED LITIGANTS AND THEY MAKE
DECISIONS THAT DETERMINE THE
TRAJECTORY OF ONE ELIFE.
WITH THESE PEOPLE OUT OF
CONTROL, THERE'S A FEDERAL
STATUE THAT ANTICIPATES THIS
KIND OF ACTIVITY FOR WHICH THERE
SHOULD BE ARREST BY THE FBI,
PROSECUTIONS BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
NOW, YOU CAN SEE THEM GOING
AFTER THE JANUARY 6 INCIDENT
AND, YOU KNOW, I CONDEMN THEM
IMMEDIATELY AND SAY THEY NEED TO
BE PROSECUTED.
SHOW A LITTLE EVEN HANDEDNESS
HERE.
THIS IS A CRIME WITH WHAT
THEY'RE DOING AND IN THE END, IF
YOU WANT TO USE YOUR ENERGIES
YELLING "ABORT THE COURT",
THERE'S CHILDREN IN THOSE HOUSES
THAT WILL SUFFER AND THERE'S
CRAZED PEOPLE THAT WILL ACT ON
THAT KIND OF LUNACY.
>> Harold: DANA WAS WHAT IT LIKE
TODAY ON YOUR SHOW?
>> Dana: I INTERVIEWED HER SON
WHEN IT JUST HAPPENED.
AND TODAY BEFORE THE BREAK, I
SAID HOW ARE YOU DOING?
SHE SAID IT'S BEEN 21 MONTHS AND
18 DAYS.
SHE LIVES WITH THE LOSS OF HER
SON FRONT AND CENTER.
SHE SAYS THERE'S NOTHING THAT
THEY CAN TAKE AWAY FROM ME.
THAT'S WHY SHE AND HER HUSBAND
HAVE DEDICATED THEMSELVES TO
MAKE SURE OTHER JUDGES CAN BE
PROTECTED.
THERE'S LEGISLATION THAT SHE'S
ASKED TO BE PASSED AND IT HAS --
BECAUSE OF THIS RECENT
SITUATION, IT'S MAYBE GOING TO
MAKE A MOVE THROUGH THE HOUSE
AND THE SENATE AND BECOME LAW
BECAUSE IT REALLY IS UNFORTUNATE
THAT -- CAN YOU IMAGINE -- LET'S
SAY THE ROE V. WADE DECISION
WENT TO OTHER WAY.
THERE WERE PROTESTERS THE OTHER
WAY, RIGHT?
PRETTY MUCH -- OKAY.
THIS IS TRUE.
IS THERE A POSITION GOING TO
BE -- WILL THE WHITE HOUSE'S
POSITION BE THE SAME IF THE
ISSUE WERE ON THE OTHER FOOT?
WE KNOW THE ANSWER IS NO.
THAT IS WHAT REALLY BOTHERS
PEOPLE.
YOU'RE JUST ASKING FOR THE
FAIRNESS.
YOU'RE ASKING FOR THE RULE OF
LAW TO BE RESPECTED.
YOU'RE ASKING FOR PEOPLE THAT
ARE ACTUALLY TAKEN IN FOR CRIMES
TO BE HELD FOR THE CRIMES AND
NOT LET OUT TO BE HELD FOR OTHER
CRIMES.
I THOUGHT HAVING HER VOICE IS SO
IMPORTANT.
SHE'S NOT A REPUBLICAN.
SHE DOESN'T TALK ABOUT BEING A
DEMOCRAT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HER POLITICAL
AFFILIATION IS.
SHE'S FOR THE RULE OF LAW.
I THINK SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER
MIGHT BE THE WORST MAJORITY
LEADER IN THE HISTORY OF THE
SENATE.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE THEY'RE
PLANNING TO DO TODAY?
TO HAVE EVERY SENATOR VOTE ON A
BILL THAT BASICALLY SAYS THERE
SHOULD BE A FEDERAL LAW THAT
WILL ALLOW ABORTION UP IN THE
MOMENT OF BIRTH IN ALL 50
STATES.
THEY WANT EVERY SENATOR TO HAVE
TO VOTE ON THAT.
IMAGINE -- JUST A DISGUSTING
NATURE OF THAT.
TO ASK PEOPLE TO DO THAT.
I THINK THERE'S ONE THING ABOUT
THE JUDGES, THE OTHER THING ON
THE MERITS TALKING ABOUT THE
LEAKS.
VERY FEW PEOPLE ARE TALKING
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE ACTUALLY
TALKING ABOUT HERE.
THAT'S WHAT THE SENATE IS VOTING
ON TOMORROW.
>> Harold: UGLY MOMENTS BRING
OUT UGLY THINGS, GREG.
WE'RE SEEING IT HERE.
FROM THE -- DANA HAS A POSITION
ABOUT THE LEGISLATION TOMORROW.
WE SHARE A VIEW OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING WITH THE JUDGES.
WHAT LAW DO YOU THINK THEY WOULD
PASS TO PROTECT JUDGES AS WELL?
>> Greg: THAT'S IMPORTANT.
THEY SHOULD ENFORCE THE LAWS
THAT ARE ALREADY HERE.
I HAVE A FEELING THAT JEN PSAKI
WOULD NOT HAVE APPROACHED THIS
TOPIC IF IT WASN'T ASKED.
THERE'S -- IT'S IMPLIED THERE'S
A POLITICAL FAVORITISM GOING ON
HERE.
THE BEST ARGUMENT FOR ABORTION
IS WATCHING THAT PROTEST.
THESE PEOPLE SHOULD NOT HAVE
KIDS.
SORRY.
IT'S JUST LIKE WHAT YOU SAID,
DANA.
WE HAVE MOVED SO FAR FROM COMMON
SENSE THAT YOU CAN HAVE AN
ABORTION UP UNTIL BIRTH.
IF YOU DISAGREE WITH IT, YOU'RE
THE EXTREMIST.
YOU'RE THE EXTREMIST.
SO IN EFFECT, THERE'S NOBODY --
LIKE IF YOU BELIEVE THAT YOU'RE
SPEAKING UP FOR SOMETHING THAT
DOESN'T HAVE A VOICE, YOU'RE
BAD?
YOU'RE IMMORAL BECAUSE THERE'S A
LIVING BEING THAT CANNOT SPEAK
AND YOU'RE -- YOU WANT TO DEFEND
THAT?
AND YOU ARE CONSIDERED THE
EXTREMIST.
THAT IS AN ABORTION OF A
THOUGHT.
>> Dana: CAN I MENTION ONE OTHER
THING ON BEN SHAPIRO'S PODCAST.
HE PLAYED A CLIP OF A LEFTIST
COMMENTATOR THAT SAID SHE WOULD
HAVE SEX WITH THE LEAKER.
IF IT TURNS OUT TO BE A
CONSERVATIVE, SHE WOULD JOYFULLY
ABORT THE FETUS AND MAKE SURE HE
KNEW ABOUT IT.
PEOPLE THAT WANT TO HAVE LIMITS
ON ABORTION ARE EXTREMISTS.
>> Jeanine: REMEMBER RALPH
NORTHUM.
ON WHETHER THE BABY COULD LIVE
OR NOT.
>> Jesse: DEMOCRATS ARE
TERRIFIED OF THE PRO CHOICE
LOBBY.
THEY DON'T WANT TO SAY ANYTHING
OUTSIDE OF PARTIAL BIRTH
ABORTION.
IT WILL DRY UP DONATIONS AND
THEY WANT TO STAY IN POWER.
THIS VIOLENCE AGAINST TRUMP
SUPPORTERS, THIS MOB THING, THAT
STARTED IN 2016.
REMEMBER THE SLEW OF ATTACKS
AGAINST TRUMP SUPPORTERS?
PEOPLE GETTING HIT IN THE HEAD
WITH CROWBARS, WITH EGGS.
PEOPLE'S CARS GETTING TORCHED.
THAT WAS NORMALIZED.
NONE OF THAT WAS PROSECUTED AND
TALKED ABOUT.
REMEMBER THE INAUGURATION?
THEY FIRE BOMBED A LIMOUSINE.
DESTRUCTION OUT THERE.
ANYTHING GOES DURING THE
ADMINISTRATION.
THE LEAKS, THE LIES, ALL OF THAT
KIND OF STUFF.
THEN YOU SAW THE SUMMER OF BLACK
LIVES MATTER.
REMEMBER?
ARSON, BAILED OUT.
THROW SOMEONE DOWN A FLIGHT OF
STAIRS?
BAILED OUT.
SHOT SOMEONE?
NOBODY TALKS ABOUT IT.
THE FACT THAT GARLAND HASN'T
SAID A WORLD -- IMAGINE IF THIS
WAS A SCHOOL SUPERINTENDENT'S
HOUSE.
>> Greg: THEY WENT TO A SCHOOL
BOARD MEETING.
>> Jesse: STEPPED UP TO A
MICROPHONE AND WAITED IN LINE.
SO COME ON.
NOW YOU PELOSI, YOU HAVE SCHUMER
AND NOW YOU HAVE THE WHITE HOUSE
OKAYING PEOPLE SURROUNDING
PUBLIC OFFICIALS HOMES.
ARE THEY REALLY OKAY WITH THAT?
LET THAT SINK IN, THE MOST
POWERFUL PEOPLE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ARE OKAY WITH
THAT.
LIKE GREG SAID YESTERDAY, WHAT
HAPPENED WITH BLACK LIVES
MATTER?
THEY THOUGHT THAT WAS RUNNING
COOL IN THE BEGINNING IN JUNE
AND JULY.
THEN IT STARTED TO BACKFIRE.
THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD STARTED TO
GET TORCHED.
WATCH WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THEIR
HOMES GET SURROUNDED.
THEY WON'T LIKE THAT.
THIS IS MOB SEASON.
THEY HAVE THE STREETS.
THEY'RE GOING TO RUN ON ROGUES.
INFLATION WILL BEAT ROE.
LAST THING, WEAR A CONDOM.
PRACTICE SAFE SEX.
BOYS AND GIRLS.
ALL RIGHT?
I KNOW IT'S NOT PERFECT.
AMERICANS ARE FORGIVING IN THE
FIRST COUPLE WEEKS.
THE FURTHER YOU GET AND YOU
START TALKING ABOUT PARTIAL
BIRTH, HAVE THAT CONVERSATION